in the last few minutes at him zahawi
has in fact tweeted here is what he has
said it's a quite long letter he said
dear prime minister thank you for your
kind words it has been after being
blessed with my loving family the
privilege of my life to serve in
successive governments and make what I
believe to have been a tangible
difference to the country I love I
arrived in this country fleeing
persecution and speaking no English here
I built a successful business and served
in some of the highest offices in
government I believe that in no other
country on Earth would my story be
possible it reaffirms my belief in the
greatness and compassion of our nation
the Lesser goes on I take particular
pride in Two achievements in government
first the vaccine rollout this saved
huge numbers of lives it is also what
has allowed us to move Beyond covert and
get our economy and Society moving again
I believe there are wider lessons for
government in the success of this
program policy making and delivery are
normally treated as two separate
processes in the vaccine team roller
they were combined and I think that
accounts for why it works so well if we
could apply this model to other parts of
government I believe it could have
transformative results
the letter goes on the second was my
role in the morning period for her late
Majesty Queen Elizabeth II those days
that celebration of her life of service
represented so much of what is best
about our country I was honored that as
Chancellor of the duchy of Lancaster I
could help ensure that everything went
smoothly and that as many people as
possible could pay their respects and
tributes to our longest serving Monarch
and then the letter goes on to say
I am concerned however about the conduct
from some of the fourth estate in recent
weeks in a week when a member of
parliament was physically assaulted I
failed to see how one headline on this
issue quote The Noose Titans reflects
legitimate scrutiny of public officials
I am sorry to my family for the toll
this is taken on them you can be assured
of my support from the back benches in
the coming years your five priorities
are the right priorities and I will do
whatever I can to help you deliver them
and there you have it that is the
response from
zahawi following
his sacking by the Prime Minister just a
few hours ago and it was in response
that letter from that he's Nadim zahari
to this letter from Rishi sunak which
reads when I became prime minister last
year I pledged that the government I
lead would have integrity
professionalism and accountability at
every level following the completion of
the independence advisors investigation
the findings of which he has shared with
us both it is clear that there has been
a serious breach of the ministerial code
as a result I have informed you of my
decision to remove you from your
position in his Majesty's government